Hello.
Let me start by showing you
a construction site
in my home city of Oslo.
(Sounds of children playing)
Did you hear something unusual?
Indeed, the noise.
The noise you hear
was from the kindergarten nearby,
not from the machine noise.
The machines were electric,
and so were the trucks that transport
materials to and from the site.
As head of the climate agency in Oslo,
the Klosterenga construction
site is a climate measure
I'm really excited about.
The workers here are opening a stream
that has been confined in pipelines
for more than 120 years.
And as climate changes in Oslo,
we are likely to experience
more heavy rain.
So we need to improve
our storm water runoff system,
and opening creeks and rivers
will help the city
to become more resilient
and avoid flooding,
as well as creating nicer areas
and contributing
to biodiversity in the city.
Klosterenga is close to being
a zero-emission construction site
run by the city of Oslo.
And running zero-emission sites is just
one example of the Oslo climate strategy.
This is how downtown of Oslo looked
when I moved to Oslo in 1989.
This is the same area today.
Oslo's climate measures have given
the city cleaner air, less noise,
safer and more human-centered streets.
Some of the measures were controversial
when first introduced,
but now a majority
of the population thinks --
even those who are not
that concerned about climate change --
think that we are creating a better city.
For too long,
discussions about climate change
have been about sacrifice.
I am here to tell you
that climate solutions
actually make a better city
and a better quality of life for everyone.
This is only the first
of five lessons we have learned
on our journey to become
an emission-free city.
And I think these lessons
can be applied almost anywhere.
So I like to share them.
So lesson number one,
confronting climate change
is about creating better cities
and better quality of life for everyone.
Including those kids in the kindergarten,
that don't have to share
their days with noisy excavators.
The second lesson
is about being ambitious.
In 2015,
the city council set a target
of reducing greenhouse gas emissions
by 95 percent by 2030
without purchasing any carbon offsets.
So aiming for real reductions.
Commitment to this goal
changed our mindset.
If we were going to reach this target,
every department had to get active,
figure out measures
and finding out how to implement them.
So second lesson, be ambitious.
A target measured in years, not decades,
provides no excuse for inaction.
In my experience,
the key challenges
of achieving climate targets
is that the division of responsibility
we see on global,
national and local levels.
In the city, the same is true.
There are differences
inside the administration,
between departments
and between agency,
which each have their own targets
and own responsibility
unrelated to climate,
and their own budget to stick to.
This makes it very difficult
to coordinate climate measures
which often cross sectoral boundaries.
Our a solution to this fragmentation
was this document:
the Oslo Climate Budget,
which we put forward
for the first time in 2016.
The first climate budget,
as far as we know.
A climate budget is a governance tool.
It structures and organizes how we can get
from climate target policies and words
to action and results.
It also makes all parts
of the administration in Oslo
a stakeholder to the climate goals.
Our climate budget,
which is measured in tons
of CO2 emissions,
is fully integrated
in the municipal budget.
And like the financial budget,
the climate budget is the responsibility
of the deputy mayor of finance.
It presents the expected
emission reduction
from the adopted climate measures.
And it clearly states what has to be done
by whom, when,
and, where relevant, at what
necessary budgetary cost.
Let me give you one example.
In 2022,
the city council decided to invest
in a carbon capture and storage facility
at the largest waste
incineration plant in Oslo.
This is the single biggest
emission source in Oslo,
accounting for 17 percent of the total.
This is a measure that has been planned
in the climate budget since 2017,
and it will be the department of business
development and public ownership,
with its specific skills, that will have
the responsibility for implementing it.
And the carbon will be captured
from 2026 and onwards.
That's the third lesson learned.
A comprehensive government system
is key to distribute responsibility
and to keep the responsible
entity accountable.
An important point is
that every agency will have to report
on the status of all their climate work
as a part of the ordinary budget process
three times a year.
So let me go back to construction.
Three years ago,
we broke ground on the piloting
of the world’s first
zero-emission construction site.
The agency of urban environment
was transforming a busy street
into a pedestrian zone
in the city center of Oslo.
They were using powerful machineries
to lift and break slabs of asphalt,
even though the machinery was so quiet
that the next door cafes and restaurants
kept their front doors open.
Today, we have more than 30 such sites,
even though electric
construction machinery
barely existed prior to this project.
This change has been made
through procurement.
In 2017,
the city decided to use procurement
to drive markets
for developing technologies
we needed to reach the climate goals.
Like in every city,
construction is a big emission source,
and in Oslo,
the municipality accounts
for approximately 20 percent of everything
that is being built.
Our procurement framework awards companies
who can provide zero-emission services.
Since 2019,
all projects by the municipality
have used this as a core tender criterium.
This is important for contractors
because it creates a predictable demand
for zero-emission solutions.
Other cities in Norway have started
using the same kind of criteria.
And the result is that the availability
of zero-emission machines
is increasing every year in Norway.
So fourth lesson,
never, ever underestimate
how much you can change
by being a demanding customer.
When the key strength of markets
is their adaptability
and when you play to that strength,
it is surprising how much
you can change in a short time.
We plan to gradually
introduce requirements
for zero emissions in all construction
sites in the city of Oslo,
both private and public, by 2030.
In the last years, the city’s quality
of air has improved significantly.
Two years ago, a columnist wrote
that the city smells so nice
now in the summer.
The reasons are reduced traffic
and the dramatic rise in proportion
of electric cars and buses.
Sometimes technology development
exceeds our expectations.
Ten years ago, few would have forecast
the numbers we see today:
82 percent of all new passenger cars
and 36 percent of new vans
have so far in 2022 been zero-emission.
And, I think, even better:
30 percent of new heavy vehicles
have so far been biogas or electric.
This is very good news
because mobility is the biggest
emission source in the city,
accounting for approximately
50 percent of our total emissions.
Transition to electric mobility has been
supported by a wide range of policies.
These include national tax exemption,
a local investment in an effective
network of charging points.
But procurement has played
an important role here, too.
Everything the municipality buys
should be delivered
by zero-emission transport.
This has been and still is
a gradual process,
but if three providers can offer it,
zero emission becomes the minimum
criteria in the procurement.
Everyone probably knows
that Norway is an oil and gas-rich nation
and many might think
that this is the reason why we can invest
in climate solutions in Oslo.
But the reality is that infrastructure
for public transport,
walking and biking
[is] financed by a system of toll roads.
We have a toll ring in Oslo,
and to go into that zone,
a non-electrical vehicle
has to pay a high price.
And that price will increase 40 percent
January 1, 2024.
This have not been [an] easy negotiation,
and taxes are always controversial.
But this is [an] important incentive
to transition away from fossil fuels.
Sometimes technology development
changes markets very rapidly.
Our climate budget had a goal of reaching
zero-emission public transport by 2028.
Thanks to decreased costs
and advanced technology,
we are now heading for reaching
that goal five years away.
(Applause)
The city's tram and meters
are already electric,
and nearly all the ferries are electric.
And by the end of 2023,
every bus in Oslo
will be electric as well.
Bus drivers love this development
because an electric bus
is more pleasant to drive,
and it creates no noise nor gases.
So fifth lesson learned,
don't underestimate
how technology changes markets
and how fast these changes can happen
and how you can incentivize them
by using the right kind of policies.
Well, we still have a way to go.
Our latest climate budget analysis
shows that we are up
for reaching a reduction
with the adaptable measures
by 62 percent by 2030.
So we are doing well,
but we have to do more,
and we need to develop,
for instance, we need to develop a system
for integrating indirect emissions.
emissions produced outside Oslo
that are related to the activities
and life in the city.
But we are working on it.
Let me finish by telling you
how I move around in the city.
I walk.
I haven't mentioned two
core aspects of urban mobility yet,
walking and biking.
The city began, years ago,
to develop as a city
for walkers and bikers.
And that's one of the things
that I really love about the city.
Thinking of a city this way
is about thinking how you organize
your everyday life,
where you can buy your groceries,
whether you can go to work,
whether your kids can use their bicycle
to [go to] the sports activities.
This is about streets,
it's about locations.
It is about safe cycling paths
and shortcuts for walking.
And connecting it all
to the rest of the city
via a clean public transport.
The latest Norwegian national survey
showed that 37 percent
of all daily trips in Oslo
are done by walking.
So, despite our very long and cold winter,
we have become a city of walkers.
And increasingly,
if you walk past
a construction site in Oslo,
you will hear no noise.
Of course, unless there is
a kindergarten [nearby].
Thank you.
(Applause)